I am a princess.
I am brave sometimes.
I am scared sometimes.
Sometimes, I am brave even when I am scared.
I believe in loyalty and trust.
I believe loyalty is built on trust.
I try to be kind.
I try to be generous.
I am kind even when others are not so generous.
I am a princess.
I think standing up for myself is important.
I think standing up for others is more important.
But standing with others is most important.
I am a princess.
I believe compassion makes me strong.
Kindness is power.
And family is the tightest bond of all.
I have heard I am beautiful.
I know I am strong.
I promise.
And when I promise something, I never ever break that promise.
I am a princess.
Long may I reign.